I want to say, sorry in advance. Um, I'm kind of sick. So I,
I might cough a lot,
which is why this video will be heavily edited and, um,
small announcements. I remember I used to have, um, free resumes. Uh,
I would share my resume and my resume template,
my cover letters and my cover letter templates to you guys. Um,
that link has been broken for the past six months, but I finally fixed them.
So they're during to description now. So you guys can check that out. Sorry.
It took so long, but all right, let's start the video. Okay.
So the first story I want to talk about is that there was someone who had a
Google offer for $277,000,
total compensation at Google. And I thought that was pretty cool.
And I was extremely jealous, but this story was on blind. Uh,
in case you don't know what blind is, is this a anonymous forum?
It's kind of like Reddit, but for work,
I stumbled upon this post on blind it's about this person who got a Google
offer and he said it was thanks to blind. You know,
he came from a CS background at a no name public university, apparently.
And he had three years of experience in the midsize tech company making
150 K. Okay.
And then after his hard work interviewing what happened is he ended up
with $277,000,
total compensation as an L for at Google.
If this isn't the American dream, I don't know what it is now.
The thread was huge. Uh, as you can see,
there were so many people congratulating him and asking him,
follow up questions, blah, blah, blah.
The thread is definitely worth reading for people who want to interview for
Google because he gives actual a lot of tips. But I don't care about that.
I read it because I never had anyone congratulate me for my job.
So I kind of pretended that was me. Yeah. Anyways,
let's see how he did it. I think that's what you guys care about.
So apparently the first thing he did is he read, uh,
let's see elements of programming interviews, which is a, uh, a book it's a,
Oh, he bought the Java version.
He said that I wouldn't have even heard about this book without seeing it
mentioned on blank. What a Brown noser,
good book though. But, um,
I actually used the Python version because I'm a snake.
And then after that he leaked coated classic classic.
He said,
I don't think I would have done as much leak code as I did if I wasn't stressed
so much on blind, grow those man. Seriously.
Why don't you just go marry blind if you like blind so much, man,
I hate this guy anyways. And then the third thing he did,
he also said that he used algo expert.io,
a site where you can practice coding interviews along with video explanations.
Now I'm kidding. He, no, he didn't. He didn't use algo, but he could have,
and it probably would have been worth it just saying. So for lead code,
apparently he did 30 questions, 30 easy,
50 medium and 20 hard like mine. And then when he interviewed at Google,
he said that he had six total, two interviews, one phone call,
which was a 45 minutes and then five onsite,
which were also all 45 minutes. And one of them,
he said was a behavioral interview. And yeah,
apparently Google does that now.
And I heard that they call it a Googley interview. Yeah.
They want to know how googly you are. If you don't know what means, uh,
for them it means, um, it just means that you're not a jerk.
If you're a Googley, then it means you're not a jerk.
So they're just making sure of that. For example,
if you're subscribed to this channel, you're googly. And if you talk about me,
because of all my ads, then that is not Google-y. Yeah.
And he said the rest of the interviews were all pure coding,
no and design questions.
After he passed all the interviews for the negotiating part, he said,
I received three competing offers of about 250,000,
but thanks to blind, thanks to blind.
I knew Google could pay more.
So he had an initial offer from Google for $250,000,
which was already pretty good by itself.
And then he used all those $250,000 offers to try to boost him
up. So I think he did some negotiating back and forth between the companies and
eventually, Oh, actually wait, let me,
he actually lied saying that the paid two 70,000 instead of two 50,000,
they said that the offers were actually two 70,000,
which eventually got him to 277,000 from Google.
You know, I do not condone lying. That is extremely unethical.
So don't get caught. Speaking of unethical and lying.
Facebook is actually the worst place for work-life balance.
According to our survey, I'm just kidding. I love Facebook.
Facebook is great. Love the company, love the people.
One of the best cultures out there.
There was a thread on blind where they asked you if they worked over 40
hours.
And if they worked during the weekend and Facebook has the highest rate
of 68%,
meaning 68% of them reported working 40 hours or more compared to Google,
which was 42%,
46% reported working on weekends for Facebook while Google only
19%. I'm actually surprised LinkedIn is there with 47%,
which surprised me because when I was there, they barely worked a week days.
And then question number three was,
do you feel pressure slash stress due to fear of PIP,
which is a performance improvement plan,
which means you're going to get fired soon or layoffs. Of course,
number one was Netflix with 80% of the people,
meaning everyone is scared shitless of getting fired,
which is the line of what I heard about the culture is that, you know,
they just fire people when they don't need them,
but that's why their products are so good. Amazon was 76%.
Facebook was 41% wellness, a big drop,
but it's still high compared to Google with a 30 to 13% and
Microsoft of 7%. Honestly,
I think a high layoff rate is actually pretty good because it keeps their
employees on their toes.
I would hate to have freeloaders and under-performers on my team is it's just
not fun. It drags you down.
And I also love to gossip whenever people are getting fired because that's
juicy. Of course these numbers are not conclusive.
I mean the sample size is extremely small and it's also biased. I know,
I know I'm pretty good with stats. I mean, what can I say?
I was a data scientist.
Now.
Another thing I want to talk about,
I want to talk about people complaining about my ads in my videos.
Now I want you to know this is actually a very common thing for you tubers to
do. And this YouTuber, Dan mace explains it perfectly.
Before you start commenting, Oh wait meeting an ad, a sponsored video.
You hurting my eyes, wasting my time.
Let me tell you something about sponsored videos.
The brand doesn't have anything to say over the actual content. If anything,
you should be stoked because for me as a creator,
I'm getting paid in order to make these films. And in order to make more films.
I just have an addiction. Like I can't stop myself. You know,
now I don't want to generalize. Right.
But I'm pretty sure that most of you, if you were in my position,
like not all, but most of you would do the same. If you were in my position,
would you put an ad? If they pay you $10,000 to do it?
Not so principled anymore. Aren't you dude.
I would suck a Dick for $10,000. Just kidding. Just kidding.
I do it for a hundred bucks, but yeah, I mean,
I actually don't think that many people are complaining.
I just really want to say that joke was this funny. Okay. Whatever.
In other news, apparently Jake Paul dissed,
the whole software engineering career, there was a video of Jake Paul.
Uh, let's see. Yeah.
A YouTuber that confronted this other utuber his name was Cody Ko and I'm
actually a fan Cody coasts. I might be biased,
but Cody Cole made a funny commentary about him saying on all like some
criticism,
he made another video where Jake Paul confronts Cody Ko to stop bullying,
stop internet bullying. When he described Cody Ko,
he said that Cody Cole was just a small backend developer,
a backend tech dude. I forgot what he said, but here's the.
I saw this Cody Ko guy for the first time when he was working at full screen,
which is like a YouTube community network as like a little, uh,
backend tech developer.
He just single-handedly disrespected a whole career saying that or
career software is small and no skill kind
of a thing, but it's okay. Cause at least Cody Cole has her back.
Just a little puny, little backend tech developer,
just so disrespectful.
Just belittling an entire career in one little statement. It's not cool,
dude. You can come from me as much as you want,
but don't come from my fellow software engineers. That's where I draw the line.
Speaking of celebrities, the next story isn't about tech,
but it's about Constance BU actress from crazy rich Asians.
She's also an actress from an ABC show called fresh off the boat.
And recently it got renewed. So apparently what happened is that on Twitter,
she actually started saying stuff like, Oh sake,
start swearing and expressing how much she was annoyed by the show being
renewed. And people were shocked about this.
Now what happened was she probably had a contract that binded her in the show
for like maybe five years or six years. I don't know how many years,
but she would have to continue filming for fresh off the boat.
But because of a recent success of crazy rich Asians and stuff like that,
she probably had better opportunities coming in, but she could not take them.
She could not take them more fulfilling job Rose because she has to do a
fresh off the boat. So on Twitter, she was just saying like, Oh this. Like,
I hate that. Okay. I forgot what she said exactly.
But it was pretty disrespectful to, to show.
I think it's honestly fine to be dissatisfied with something or like
dissatisfied with your current job. If you have better opportunities coming in.
That's totally fine. I understand that.
But I think it's extremely disrespectful to publicly curse your
employers, right? I mean, isn't an awkward,
if you go back to work next year with the same employer,
fresh off the boat and everyone knows that you just hate your job.
Like how are you supposed to work with them now? It's terrible.
So I just want to end this video by saying.
That was an extremely Google-y thing you did.
All right.